joint russian and belarusian military
exercises near the ukrainian border
up to 30 000 russian soldiers and most
of the belarusian army are taking part
in the 10 days of drills including
missile defense systems tanks and
fighter jets
moscow has around a hundred thousand
troops stationed close to ukraine's
borders
ukraine invoked a clause from the
so-called 2011 vienna document which is
an international agreement on military
transparency on which russia is a
signatory of
demanding moscow provide detailed
information and time frames for military
maneuvers
several western countries including
france launched fresh diplomatic efforts
this week to persuade russia to back
down so far those efforts have failed to
bear significant fruit
moscow says it's demand that there never
be further nato expansion east including
ukraine is being ignored
ukraine's foreign minister told al
jazeera russia's concerns are
illegitimate and ukraine would not
concede to moscow's demands
russia violated virtually every rule of
international law related to security in
the last years
so now it wants to impose on others the
discussion
that you guys are expanding nato or
doing something else
and that inflicts damage on my security
the last thing
the west should do in response to that
question using is actually to agree to
take this concern seriously
instead
it's us ukraine and other countries who
suffered from russia's actions should
ask them a question
how how will you
russia
ensure your security without inflicting
damage
on
the security on our security
new satellite images published by a
private us company
show what it says is new russian
military deployment near ukraine's
border
more nato troops and weapons are being
sent to bolster the alliance's eastern
flank
in a rare press conference in the
russian-backed separatist held territory
the leader of the self-declared donetsk
people's republic accused ukraine of
planning a military solution to the
crisis
something ukraine denies
i do not rule out that ukraine can
attack at any time they have everything
ready the concentration of forces and
capabilities allows them to do it at any
moment as soon as there is a political
decision
russia says it has no intention of
invading ukraine but it says it will be
forced to take unspecified military
technical action if its demands are not
met moscow's main demand is that ukraine
never becomes a nato member and that's
something that the us and its nato
allies say is a non-starter
diplomatic efforts to defuse the crisis
continue to fail charles stratford al
jazeera kharkiv eastern ukraine